[Laughter]
in hell my God I'm vegan
bro not only am I vegan I'm Hindu by
origin and you just sprayed me with beef
[Music]
J I'm J rnap I'm Mich Richards I'm
romish rang aan and this is snack Wars
on sport Bible with the return of League
of the own we're going to be trying
snacks from the UK and then pitting them
against snacks from the rest of the
world let's see how it goes well we got
mix oh tiasu tiasu versus I'm guessing
apple pie minc pie no that's a mince
that's not Apple how can you tell you
got x-ray
vision that might be apple pie oh okay
why is it got the star on it
then it is apple pie oh okay a who's a
muggy now I didn't call you a muggy why
are you using the spoon for
the shut your
mouth for that you got to have a big
bit that's meat
mints I Love A Min by man I do as well
at Christmas when they're warm oh my God
that's going to have to what is that ter
that's good I want to be Italian when I
was younger so I'm playing football
that's how it you look Italian don't you
thanks mate how much work does it
cost you know what try that have you
tried it it's great this is a tough
battle for me m you ever have U when you
were in you're in CA U you would have
had time to I
imagine I'm
just did you learn much Italian proba
Italiano really who I like
[Laughter]
it I have got
thisam Nik m m two
H that's
Spanish little bit Hy I'm actually
finishing this now I quite like the
mints me too I'm going to go mint pie I
would have gone T Su right it is nice
normally I would have gone T but I think
it was a quality mint fine reminded me
of
Christmas oh Lord sprinkles sprinkles on
bread oh so that's a famous Australian
snack called fairy bread a I'm going
have a little try that yeah go for it
you got sweet too F yeah how is it yeah
good
why we there's three
bits it's like what's that film with
starts fooding food I was expecting not
to like it but I am a fan I'm not sure
about that can't be good for you though
what is this cucumber cream cheese yeah
your classic cucumber sandwich oh
cucumber sandwich okay I don't know
about the layering of that cuc I would
go much thinner on the Cucumber there
that's too much yeah the bread to
cucumber ratio is completely SK I did I
made that bit who's responsible for this
absolutely dropped a bollock on this one
mate it'sing by the way okay okay you
think this is better
okay you know what you had to say
that is that like a poshing that I guess
so it feels like that's what you'd eat a
cricket you have it with afternoon tea
yeah this is a this is a tough one
because they're both not the best are
they I like that I like both of them
actually this is a surprise element to
me cuz I thought I was going to ha but
something about the way you fed it to me
like a baby bird enhance enhance my
enjoyment of it I'm going to go with the
uh you prefer the cucumber sandwich
cucumber yeah J I mean I've got a sweet
too so I'm going to have to go that way
I'm going cucumber sandwich that's okay
I'm about numbered oh this reminds me
when I was an apprentice at Bournemouth
people to come come and have their sort
of drink at half time we used to make B
well what I would say is they've given
me a vegan option but I don't I don't
I've never heard of people making mmart
into a drinks stink mate it smells like
and when people say I want B Ru you just
have to question them yeah I really love
Marmite that's minging I've had two sips
for some
reason in hell I'm sorry
Gea are youing joking you've just ruined
I can't see you on there anyway you're
in cage oh my God sorry Ro what the mate
I'm just this my first wear of these
just got it all over the are you joking
wait these are air memory phon WR with
you but good job they machine washable
sorry ROM seriously literally sprayed
out the most stainy thing that you could
possibly spray out your mouth you mad
I'm vegan
bro not only not only am I vegan I'm
Hindu by origin and you just sprayed me
with beef
jice you've got beef juice got me I
got's beef juice all over me right oh my
that's the draw I can't go to see my mom
I can smell cow on
you I can I can smell M's beef juice on
you I know have you have you been trying
Ma's beef juice again I mean unless
you've got like liquid dog in
these I think we know what the winner is
yeah we not got tast you got a pumpkin
spice L I think I'll aim this way just
just in case r yeah that's right the
darker one you spray all over me but
that one you just keep careful with that
that is delicious it's not really but
it's delicious compared to that beef
juice you like that that is tasty that
is great man yeah it's it's pumpkin
vegan
pumpkin yeah if you if you can catch
them talking
about a big one on this show they're
really quick and N once you get hold of
one you can't eat it yeah guys who gets
the point uh I just coffe in pumpkin
pumpkin spice L for sure you're no
you're not God voila
ooh God pickled Walnut pickled Walnut
versus it's like sauerkraut yeah pickled
sauerkraut shredded cabbage put that in
Burgers though a lot don't they or not I
think so I don't know yeah yeah hot dogs
hot dog hot dogs that's right what do
you put pickle walnuts in the bin not
really diving I'm not diving for the
folks here are you come on big meates do
you want me to do it
oh I'm going to put this one first okay
go ready don't listen first of all that
yeah but that's nuclear that liquid
don't get it go on I'm not biting why
are you feeding him I just my
fetish oh that's is it all right I got a
small one for you
mixx
initially not great did it get better
it's all right can you see going to love
it oh no I'm surprised you did that why
don't you just spray it all over my
jacket oh Jesus
Christ it does now you've chewed it and
spat it out into the thing look like a
used nappy that that's
disgusting I can't eat that just oh it
tastes like this challenge will be so
much better if you w't hear though why
we'll be eating meat and
stuff like this is p purely to you we're
just eating
vegetarians we can eat burgers against
that bacon sandwich proper it was tough
to put
together yeah yeah imagine tough trip to
Tes
SK it get the point then guys well I
mean they're both not great I would say
these this is all right I'm going for
the SRA bear in mind they were able to
keep that down I let's go sauerkraut but
it's a it's a pretty pour bun
oh pulparindo pulparindo what they're
spicy or something is they they're from
Mexico oh we're going there soon very
popular are they spicy I think you have
to find out
guys unusual
it what does it taste though well it's
got Tam it's Tamarind right yeah I can't
figure out if I don't like it or it
might be the only thing I eat for the
rest of my life you know mean it's like
not there's something about it yeah I'm
not having where' you put is it an Under
Armor under
[Laughter]
AR so it's like touches that liquid and
then you get more of it on the
bowl I mean this is an absolute piece of
I've got a lot of problems with
this I am the fact that you even putting
in your mouth and doing the things it
looks wrong also just having this thing
that you've lick just sitting in the top
of the bot disgusting you're not going
to go through that in one go I mean Big
M can't get out of his
mouth is it possible do you want to just
clip this up and put it on only
fans right
there it's way better than that he's
he's putting it back for his own safety
that gives you that blue tongue as well
so what get the point guys I'm going
brain liquor brain I think is a no
brainer it's pindo bindo bindo that's my
favorite and the UK
wins on you come on you K what on you
Kai Jesus
that's he just threw up a bit did I
threw up my mouth little on that
one oh my God